entre 20 et 25% de baisse par rapport à
2010 neuf en ce début d'année 2022 la
fréquentation des salles de spectacles
et de cinéma est encore fragile dans les
yvelines la levée successifs des
restrictions n'effraie pas les
spectateurs au théâtre coluche de
plaisir les dernières représentations se
sont joués à guichets fermés soit 900
places c'est plutôt un soulagement de
toute façon depuis les annonces qui
concernait le 28 février
sa rebooster totalement la fréquentation
des théâtres et les ventes donc on
retrouve presque un niveau normal de
fréquentation quelques on l'a vu il ya
deux trois ans dans un ancien abri
coheed donc on est plutôt très très
heureux je pense pas du tout que et
qu'il y ait la moindre inquiétude de la
part du public du côté de la scène
nationale aussi pas d'annulation du
public qui répond présent si peu de
représentations ont eu lieu depuis la
levée des restrictions la direction note
que le masque est plus une question
d'habitude elle a beaucoup qui ont
conservé le mas lors des représentations
de la semaine dernière ce qui au vu du
nombre de contaminations qui permet
encore assez important me semble assez
assez logique et assez normal voilà mais
il y en a qui en ont profité aussi pour
tout d'un coup respirer mais je pense
que ses habitudes vont cesser petit à
petit depuis ce lundi 14 mars le
contrôle du pass vaccinale n'est plus en
vigueur les saisons culturelles pour les
salles de spectacles prennent fin entre
mai et juin